and the next category is ashley what is
it best rant best
rant oh god there's so many
so many this is this is just like ninety
percent of the positions like this
right it's like there's eight there
could be like four or five nominees
when aren't we ranting about something
there are some standout rants i will say
this yeah those are my favorites let's
look at the nominees
the great burger debate i mean we just
saw the man in the motel animals
play the club let's see it in 4k yeah
hamburger is not a by itself
hamburger is not a patty by itself you
got like
potatoes you got vegetables what are you
doing again
because oh my god you know what's a good
around when we're just [ __ ] screaming
from the get-go i
do not remember being that heated what i
i
couldn't shut you up i remember you
being heated because i was laughing the
entire time
this this was obviously me running on
pure adrenaline and rage i think so
because i do not remember like i'm not
looking at this and i do not remember
saying the words i did or being that
i've never seen you this is everything
answer apology i do not remember the
words that i said i do not apologize for
your lapse of judgment
honestly i would give up like if i sound
like this i'd give an apology video i
don't remember
don't eat me i don't get heated i wasn't
very monkey
this angry in my life i'm sorry i think
i was more angry here than i was
breaking [ __ ] in your video
there are too many sabers in fate we're
just talking about the series we haven't
gotten into fate law
we're not getting into that
literally anything but this topic
anything please the next one is my
personal favorite
school days was the masterpiece of that
generation for episode three i believe
yeah yeah one of our early ones it's so
funny that you say like the school days
like mal is either like a ten or two
that's yeah i was definitely one of
those people who put it aside i know you
did your piece of [ __ ]
because because i know exactly what my
what is going on here
look how bare the studio was back now
yeah i think this is the first time we
ever got heated on the podcast yeah yeah
it didn't take us long three episodes
three hours
what were we doing for the first time
were we civil in the first two episodes
i guess we were
um yeah i mean this this is a classic
moment for me this is something yeah
this is i'm still proud of this moment
this is uh still an
awful opinion awful it is awful it's
terrible despicable frankly um
and i don't know why he has a job
judging other people's mouth when this
exists yeah right
that's i'm clearly not fit for the job
uh next one is bowling is boring it is
dude this is
i was very passionate about it i still
am very passionate about this
play the clip bowling is like the most
depressing activity out of all of the
activities
really i think so i feel like bowling
with alcohol
is fun it's fine but bowling without
alcohol is
boring
god describes 95 percent of activity
why did you sound so unsure you're like
is it boring
i think because i just realized
i was just like talking [ __ ] you weren't
talking [ __ ]
it was it was like it was like yeah the
floor is made out of
floor it was kind of that moment the
scissors was generating as it came out
of your mouth
i'm pretty sure i just i'm pretty sure i
just auto-generated that sentence as i
was like
moving my mouth that was like
text-to-speech
i don't know it's like the phone auto
prediction bowling is an activity which
is
bowling and finally the dragon ball
fanbase
is the worst oh yeah i love this clip i
love this round you just see the dumbest
[ __ ] take it's always from a [ __ ]
dragon ball after yeah or like someone
who like
just tweets about dragon ball yeah it
still is true uh i think out of
everything
this was the most rantiest episode oh
yes
yeah because we are like no no one was
safe not that episode we were like if
we're gonna [ __ ] on one fan base we're
[ __ ] on everything we literally [ __ ]
on like every anime fan base that exists
honestly that's my favorite that was my
favorite to film in terms of just
ranting about different things
i don't think that's gonna win i don't
think that's gonna win because i think
that's gonna win
i feel like that was just an entire
episode of ranting and
you couldn't like the dragon ball one
stood out the most but
yeah we could have we could have put any
kind of money genuinely believe the
saber one's gonna win
really i have a fight i feel the great
burger debate
great burger debate or school days i i
feel the great burger debate is going to
be powered by the man in motel animated
because that went
quite viral but there's only one way to
find out i guess
let's do it trash dates awards best rant
goes to
the great burger debate
again no surprise though i mean it's
hard to
nail you down it's hard to nail down a
more
like one of like i mean there's so many
iconic clips right but the great burger
debate
is an iconic clip for just trash because
how wrong in general
yeah no because for how right he is
i like lounge i like how whenev whenever
like someone outside of the podcast
hangs out with us they get surprised
that we do the actual
the actual things that we say on the
podcast yeah they were like i thought
the hamburger
thing was a bit like you actually like
it i remember the first time
like i remember the first time we were
interviewing ashley and we were at the
denny's and i ordered a hamburger
gives me the most evil look and she's
like oh this was real
you guys actually do this [ __ ] we do we
do
this isn't just for entertainment i
remember like when ken came on as well
like uh we went we went to like a uh
went to an italian restaurant
yeah yeah and we ordered pizza and i
didn't eat my crust
and he was like whoa and the ken's
producer was just like oh
this is this is a thing you you weren't
[ __ ] around it's a reference to trash
you like that guy from trash taste right
now what was the percentages
um the great burger debate won with 32.6
percent of the vote
in second place was school days of
course yeah with 23 percent what came
last
what came last was bowling is boring wow
fair enough it's probably not as
memorable as the other ones for sure
yeah well there you go